Let's get 1 more view into how this relationship
between grammars and parsing states plays out.
I've written a new grammar over here on the left,
but actually if you think about it, it's simpler than our old grammars.
Since this one isn't recursive, there are only a finite number of strings in the language--
INT + string and INT alone.
Let's say that the full input is going to be INT + INT,
which is not in the language of the grammar,
but thus far, we've only seen a single token--INT.
Our parser has to handle good input and also malformed input.
Not everything out there on the web is super clean.
We're going to want to write a web browser that can tell the difference between
the good and the bad, the wheat and the chaff.
So what I'd like you to do is figure out after just 1 token of the input,
what are some parse states we could be in?
I've listed 7 possible parse states in this multiple multiple-choice quiz.
I would like you to check each one if we could be in it, after seeing only 1 token of this input.